je propose maintenant de découvrir la
sélection livre de typhaine qui est venu
pour cette rentrée avec des choses très
agréables pour que nos enfants puissent
avoir encore plus de copains et les
copines
oui et vous savez souvent les premières
entrées ont lieu à la crèche en fait
parce que les petits rentrer première
année deuxième année maver deux ans et
demi c'est voilà c'est la crèche c'est
un peu compliqué parfois l'après je me
tourne vers le papa le jeune papa qui
est à côté de vous amener votre fils à
l'école bien sûr et alors ça s'est passé
comment sa lutte et est rentrée en cp à
ses fins c'est comme ça a été ok son
petit nom c'est quoi nolan nolan avait
écouté en salut nolan et la maman aussi
qui nous regardent vraisemblablement je
reviens vers vous donc tout s'est bien
passé à peu près on va dire pour la
plupart de nos enfants et petits enfants
néanmoins on va commencer avec un livre
pour les tout petits c'est celui ci
voilà alors pour leur donner envie
d'aller à la crèche j'ai ce livre la
nina à la crèche demichel eliane et yves
bruel
alors l'idée c'est de montrer que la
crèche c'est un petit monde à part mais
où on s'amuse beaucoup
alors ça commence avec nina qui ce
réveil de la sieste est bon évidemment
elle est un petit peu triste parce que
sa maman n'est pas là mais elle va vite
oublier cette tristesse pour aller jouer
dans le jardin et aller de découverte en
découverte et notamment se rendre compte
qu'il vient il ya plein d'amis autour
d'elle pour partager ses découvertes et
en fait j'ai bien aimé ce livre parce
que justement ça permettra aux enfants
de se dire qu'ils vont construire un
monde
rien qu'à eux et après ils pourront
retrouver leurs parents et avoir une
deuxième journée et c'est un livre
musical agrémenté je vais vous poser la
question aux perspectives chansonnette
je sais pas si on le voit bien mais
marquez et d écoute en ligne histoire
chanson when i was there qui avait cédé
dedans pour voilà écouter et puis vous
pouvez retrouvez aussi toutes les
chansons en ligne
voilà pour donc en fonction de ce que
vous préférez si j'ai bien compris c'est
par les reculs nous qui nous expliquer
qui explique le fonctionnement de la
crèche à non pas du tout déjà il ya une
partie qui se passait la crèche et une
partie qui se passe à la maison pour
montrer que une journée à la crèche
c'est pas une punition et la journée se
continue après
mon avec papa et maman et en plus bien
voilà c'est juste une fable avec des
petites chansonnettes ça plaît beaucoup
aux enfants
vraiment je le conseille après la crèche
et l'école élémentaire comme pour nolan
voilà alors ce petit livre là ça
s'appelle un oiseau sur mon épaule de
6000 de lacroix aux éditions mijade et
figurez vous que cette petite fille elle
s'est dit j'ai préparé mon cartable j'ai
rangé mon doudou je suis prête pour
l'école on sait pas si les grandes
sections école élémentaire tout va bien
se passer je vais me faire des amis et
finalement une oiseaux se pose sur son
épaule et c'est oiseaux qui a l'air
magnifique lui sur de drôles de mots au
ne t'approche pas des autres ils sont
mieux que toi finalement qu'est-ce que
tu fais et c'est oiseaux vous pourrez
dire que c'est un petit peu le manque de
confiance en soi la timidité qu'on peut
ressentir quand on arrive à l'école il
faudra qu'une autre petite fille zoé
finalement viennent pour rompre
en fait tous ces sentiments un petit peu
contradictoire qui peuvent assaillir nos
enfants quand ils rentrent à l'école
j'ai trouvé ce livre merveilleux c'est
une jolie fable en fait pour donner
confiance aux enfants parce que
finalement l'amitié bien c'est ce qu'on
trouve à l'école quand on y va
mais parfois c'est difficile à créer
pour les beaucoup entre nous peut-être
si nolan est un petit petit mais pour
ses premières entrées
ça peut être un joli livre à offrir un
handicap voilà les enfants qui
appréhendent un petit peu
sans oublier le doudou et pourtant et le
doudou un jeune est vide ou mais du coup
elle l avait laissé parce qu'à l'école
élémentaire ou en grande section doit
laisser se sont bien débrouillés pour ce
faire moi je vous laisse pas partir
encore tout de suite parce que je crois
vous avez un roman pour nous mon cher
ami déjà ça veut tout dire
alors là c'est pour les cm2
et 6e déjà on est dans la lecture c'est
un très joli romande le double en vilain
et ça se passe pas le jour de la rentrée
mais c'est les seconds rentrée vous
savez quand elle nouveaux qui arrivent
et c'est le journal intime de thomas qui
voit arriver ce nouveau qui s'appelle
patrick or patrick je vous l'annoncé un
prénom hyper nascar en cm2 voilà
impossible
c'était super bowl dans les années 60 70
des vêtements super nul est alors le but
c'est de pas être son copain mais ça va
pas du tout se passait comme ça parce
que patrick veut être le copain de
thomas est donc dans ce journal intime
on va découvrir tout un tas de
péripéties qui va les amener évidemment
à être amis c'est vraiment un roman très
très sympa on découvre des parents en
dessous tout la plupart du temps dans le
fond adorable des enfants quand même
assez bagarreur et qui sont prêts à tout
pour être populaire amoureux a mis
finalement le conseil voilà c'est
vraiment un super livre avec dans les
mains de tous les enfants de 9-10 ans
elle est super elle est le tout dernier
c'est encore un roman c'est pour les
ados oui est bon plus tôt pour les
filles je vous avoue parce que ça
s'appelle princesse incognito ça se
passe à rosewood hall et c est le
premier tome de rose ou de chroniques
ours de connie green chez casterman
l'idée c'est qu'on arrive dans un
pensionnat et des listes génial
pensionnat anglais voilà tout sombre je
suis imaginé magnifique piscine enfin
voilà et il ya une princesse qui est là
incognito
alors l'idée ça va être de découvrir qui
est la princesse pourquoi elle est là
il ya plein de mystère c'est passionnant
il ya un charme
la petite orpheline bien sûr qu'ils
aient un crachin pascal c'est le livre
pour les gens qui adorent les princesses
et celles qui adorent les détester voilà
c'est un moment très sympa hein y'a rien
de fabriquer ses charmes
on est allé je vous soupçonne de fayoter
parce qu'effectivement il ya des étoiles
dans la tiers de la princesse là avec
eric la plein de mystères franchement je
conseille c'est un peu la fantasy est un
petit peu mystérieux mais c'est super
remercie en tout cas pour cette belle
rentrée scolaire et littéraire avec vous
pour nos enfants pour se faire plein
d'amis de copains et de copines